foreign
[Music]
on the night of June 4th
you performed an exorcism
that was not an exorcism
the majority of cases do not require an
exorcism
98 I recommend in buying him to doctors
and psychiatrists
the other two percent
we have more questions for you father
Mort you have a problem with me you talk
to my boss
they Pope that is the case
that needs your attention
bring me the priest
I'm here to help Julia
wrong right
they cautioned their secrets buried
there
the other concealer
the church escort against this demon
before
the body can cover the top we need to
find out why
you've been trying you took the Bates
whatever you do you only do because God
allows it
did you allow that
imagine what could happen if the devil
possessed the soul of the Pope's
Exorcist who will defend you
my faith
has no required defense
foreign
[Music]